which is chef T's favorite basket
quarter hello everybody my name is chef
T on a Jeep
I am a sous chef and I also have a
cooking channel on YouTube called
cooking with teeth so heavy but my heart
is light and today I'm gonna be trying a
bunch of fast food cheeseburgers that
could be delivered to your front door
and or you can pick it up if you guys
want to take a drive while social
distance seeing obviously so let's get
started
today we're gonna be eating Shake Shack
burger king in and out Wendy's and
Mickey D's
okay McDonald's so we're gonna be trying
the first burger Shake Shack so it looks
pretty good you know it's like the meat
looks good it doesn't look too like
broken down in like mushy you can tell
that they like chunks of meat in here
like like real ground beef it came with
ketchup I always assume that when they
get they send certain sauces to the
table or whatever it is that they want
the customer to eat it
so let's go take the first bite shake
shot classic I think the meat is
seasoned perfectly right now and I'm
eating the Shake Shack burger I honestly
feel like I'm at somebody's barbecue and
like they made me a cheeseburger
straight up there's no lettuce there's
no tomato there's no onion so I think
it's perfect for like people who are
picky eaters nice it's nice and simple
Burger King yeah you gotta have a really
good burger to be called Burger King I
think to just say that you're the king
of the burgers you know but let's look
at it here seems to me like this
mayonnaise on here some ketchup onion
tomato pickles Saban has some sesame
feeds on it
so if you have a sesame allergy I wonder
if they take care of you it's not that
bad I think I really my first bite had
like hippo a and I love pickles I think
this burger is cool because it has you
know it has like the onions and the
tomatoes makes it a little bit more
complex than just a plain cheese burger
gives you a little bit more flavor a
little bit more texture you know well
something to look forward to in each
bite this burger is definitely for
somebody who knows what they want to eat
I think that that's their motto have it
your way
as a Burger King the Burger King made it
for you your way is you know what he
wanted he meat we are eating a Wendy's
Burger now maybe it was hot really hot
when they wrapped it so kind of filled a
little bit salty because it's like maybe
the steamed there's mustard and there's
ketchup and there's onions and pickles
cheese obviously and it looks like the
patty is almost like a square and it
looks like the bun was toasted on some
like a poncho or like you know a surface
because you can tell that there's like
oil and browning on it it's cool you
gotta love a crispy pickle on a burger I
think I think all of these funds can be
toasted TBH like toasted a little maybe
though maybe they were like a little bit
more
cheese before they got here though
because it is the delivery system I like
the first nickel bit mustard on it and I
love pickles our monster McDonald's okay
I haven't liked the color of the rabbit
non-speaking BL is my favorite color but
like it just looks cool so we got
pickles we got some looks like some
small diced onions I definitely see why
people like it you know I feel like as a
child I used to eat McDonald's all the
time I think overall the seasoning of
the McDonald's burger is kind of just
like I like how they have the small
diced onions on the burger though
because I kind of find that when I eat
burger sometimes and I want to get that
bite of that onion like when it's like
in a circle or just like slice like that
it's kind of hard to eat so I kind of
like the way they have this small diced
onions going on that's a good thing I
think I definitely understand why people
love McDonald's oh oh
in and out okay like ooh look at that
nice chose like toasty toasty onion
cheese lettuce tomato and that spread
sauce I don't know if you guys have had
in and out you know I was like an L a
burger it's like the staple of LA but
you can trust in and out to make a
burger the same each and every time I
love the spread sauce I think that's
great because there's like the relish
inside the spread sauce it's just pretty
much like ketchup and mayo cuz I got
Thousand Island the lettuce is like nice
and fresh and crispy you can tell that
they like care about the quality of I'm
not saying I am the queen of burger
eating and I know everything but I think
that this burger is great which is chef
cheese favorite fast-food burger
I don't all five burgers in and out was
definitely my favorite burger but you
know it's fresh you taste the freshness
I really like
check burger two though the burger patty
from Shake Shack is more seasoned than
the burger patty comminute now I
definitely enjoy trying all these
burgers I hope you guys enjoyed this
video though and I hope this really
helps you guys out actually
[Music]